c'est pour toi j'achète pas oui j'arrive
et tout le monde se traînent ici
accélère un peu le bon plan
dehors la votre silence 50 plus on sait
jamais rien dit de toute façon
salut quel beau c sont réelles et il est
à côté il faut qu'on fasse venir ici on
n'est peut-être pas obligé de taper le
concert
m
mamadou kanté intervient
on ne m'avait pas la fine bouche non
qui se trouverait enfin vous écriviez
une chanson pour l'autre bord c'est ce
mec qui capitaux
on va voir ce que vous avez toujours la
cote j'arrête vous l'avez bien phû
produits bio coup d'arrêt
parti par ont j'en ai laissé filer avec
ses collègues
et franchement tu te prends le fera
quand même pas trop faire chier en
faisant sa starlette
on peut dire que je fais partie des murs
chez vous on étudiera son mariage et
la fermer